[Musique]
la vedette de ce festival c'est trop dur
cela bien sûr mais c'est aussi toute
cette foule cosmopolite tous ces fanas
du cinéma qui gravitent autour du
festival
c'est le cas de ville d'une originale
des planches celle qu'on appelle
marguerite de france vous avez déjà
tourné dans les films j'ai fait 80 films
80 vous trouvez que c'est pas une vie
une vie d'artiste
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut de plus pour
le prouver vous allez les voir c'est
pour ça que quand un truc également et
cantatrice d'opéra pour les autres
reprises je chante pour nom c'est
gratuit on parlait de comédie musicale
c'est un petit peu la vedette du
festival les personnes qui pensent en
paix tant que je suis est grand temps
que vous suivez toutes ces personnes
mais je les connaissais pas ce que je
connaissais tout j'étais toujours à
paris avec les artistes une carte
d'artiste méric une carte d'artiste
qu'est ce que vous apporte le festival
cette année
qu'est-ce qu'il vous attend à bagneux
pas fini j'arrive vu ses débuts c'est la
joie d'être congratulé on me dit madame
c'est vous c'est vous car stones
chantent kong ou à je dis bien sûr c'est
tout le monde avait ceux d'autres mondes
de dépasser je cherche jusqu'à 140 ans
vous verrez toujours à venir
mais vous avez quand même mais j'ai pas
d'âge et 40 ans c'est tout
[Musique]